Doctor Who is coming to Disney Plus
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so it was recently reported that doctor
who will be streaming on Disney plus as
of 2023 in line with the new series of
Doctor Who with the new doctor shooty
gatwa now whilst the BBC and bad wolf
who are owned by Sony will retain
creative control Disney plus will
basically distribute it to a wider
audience meaning that no longer are the
days of having to watch it on BBC One
and having International audiences have
to wait for the syndication now
historically BBC was working with ABC
and was basically using BBC America and
ABC to distribute Doctor Who to the
American audiences now that deal no
longer exists they have parted ways and
and now Distributing through Disney plus
which honestly is better because this
means that everyone in the world can
watch Doctor Who as soon as it drops now
what does this mean for the future of
Doctor Who well Disney plus now have a
vested interest in the property and will
be investing money into it meaning there
will be a much higher budget for things
like VFX having the show on Disney plus
as well is going to mean that it's going
to be seen by a much larger audience and
although ratings for Doctor Who on BBC
One have dropped in the most recent
years those ratings aren't going to mean
anything because quite honestly the BBC
could have 30 people watching it could
be seen as a commercial failure but on
Disney plus you could have millions and
millions of people watching and it would
be hugely successful this is the power
of distribution Doctor Who is in a way
being regenerated you've no doubt
already heard that in Jody Whittaker's
final episode she regenerated into none
other than David Tennant the guy who
played the 10th doctor meaning that
David Tennant is now the 14th doctor and
we will be seeing him and his adventures
along with Donna Noble and a whole array
of other people from that era back on
our screens into 2023 for the 60th
anniversary special all of this is being
held by none other than Russell T Davis
who is coming back to save the sinking
ship speaking of sinking ship the Doctor
Who has tanked in the ratings over the
last few years
Jody Whittaker's opening episode had 11
million viewers and slowly as the series
progressed that number dropped now you
could argue that it was the story it
just wasn't interesting
but maybe just maybe and this is going
to link in with the Disney plus deal
people just aren't watching the BBC
anymore young people today don't have TV
licenses because there's no point in
having one in the UK we have to have a
TV license I know it's an archaic thing
but essentially you need to pay 12 pound
a month if you own a TV and you can
receive live channels such as the BBC
ITV Channel 4 Etc people nowadays
especially younger people don't watch
live television I don't watch live
television I have a TV license because
every now and then something will pop up
and I will watch it such as Doctor Who
but now it's going on to Disney Plus
what's the point I don't need to pay to
watch BBC when I can watch it on Disney
plus which I already pay for and that's
where my idea comes in was it the
writing of Doctor Who that really tanked
the ratings or is it a shift in the
social Paradigm of how we view content
is everyone just switching to streaming
services because they're a lot easier
and often cheaper than paying for cable
television in the UK there are two major
television providers you have Sky TV and
you have virgin media I cannot tell you
the last time I watched anything on
either of those platforms but I can tell
you when I last watched Netflix and when
I last watched Disney plus and I think
that's the key audiences are now
switching to streaming services and the
BBC know this that's why they struck a
deal with Disney plus they want more
eyes on Doctor Who and it just makes a
lot of sense young people aren't
watching the BBC fine let's put our most
valuable product or one of our most
commercially successful products that we
own onto a platform that is going to be
seen by millions now there are other
factors at play they've brought back
Russell T Davis to Hell on the ship who
famously brought back Doctor Who in 2005
and made it the commercial success it
has been over the last 20 years now
Doctor Who was always popular it's been
going since 1963 and it always had a
core audience but it was never as
popular as when Russell T Davis held the
ship since he left we had Stephen
Moffett and Chris gibnell rating slowly
dropped after Russell T Davis left and
the BBC noticed so he's come back to try
and revive the show to regenerate it to
regenerate Doctor Who I personally am
super excited about the 60th anniversary
I've already made a video on basically
what's going to be happening in the 60th
anniversary based on set leagues that
we've had and if you want to see that
click the card up in the top right there
but sadly we will be waiting until
November next year before these specials
drop but
it's not all bad because we're going to
be getting three but let me know what
you think are you excited about the
future of Doctor Who now that Chris
chibnell has left and I also want to
know your opinions on why you think the
ratings went down do you agree with me
that is potentially an issue with people
just not watching the BBC or do you
think the main thing was the
storytelling I think both of them play a
factor
but are leaning more towards people just
want to watch streaming services but I
want to know what you think but if
you're new to the YouTube channel make
sure you hit subscribe and press the
Bell notification so you don't miss a
single video whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully Financial
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching stay safe
and I'll see you next week
[Music]